Trascrizione: Stefania Venturetti
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buonasera.
Sono qui perché ho seguito il mio cuore.
Venti mesi fa ero a Toronto
dove un mio amico,
un ingegnere strutturale
che ha costruito quell'edificio,
m'ha messo un libro in mano.
L'ho letto.
Era [del] suo architetto preferito.
Allora l'ho letto due volte.
Mi sono innamorato.
E ho lasciato tutto
per venire qui, a Firenze,
con la certezza di
scrivere una sceneggiatura.
Sono venuto a Firenze
per capire meglio il passato
ma quello che ho trovato ha grande
rilevanza per il nostro futuro collettivo.
La storia di una città,
il genio Filippo Brunelleschi
e la sua Cupola meravigliosa.
Forse ho anche trovato
un nuovo segreto della Cupola.
La Cupola di Brunelleschi
era ricca di tecnologia.
Era infatti l'Internet del Rinascimento.
Le statistiche della Cupola
fanno impressione:
29mila tonnellate di pietra,
di mattone,
di legno.
Creata senza computer,
senza elettricità,
solo col cervello, con le mani.
E con filo a piombo.
Esistevano grandissimi problemi:
come fare a sollevare
1000 tonnellate di pietra
a un cantiere alto 66 metri?
Ma l'hanno fatto. E l'hanno fatto tutto.
E vi dico questo:
La Cupola di Brunelleschi
era molto di più.
Era un cantiere vivo:
pieno di idee, di filosofia,
di matematica e scienza.
All'inizio, la Cupola di Brunelleschi
era un concetto.
Doveva essere inventata.
Come Internet, doveva essere inventata.
Internet non esiste senza fili
del telefono, computer, modem
e roba del genere.
Per costruire la Cupola, Filippo
Brunelleschi ha inventato macchine,
calce, e il metodo di lavoro.
E che è successo?
Dopo 25 anni,
tutte le idee e il lavoro
che ha messo dentro la Cupola
[sono andate] alla prossima generazione:
cervelli come Michelangelo
e Leonardo da Vinci.
È una cosa strana.
Senza tutte le opere [e i problemi]
risolti da Brunelleschi sulla Cupola,
Michelangelo non avrebbe avuto
le basi per le sue opere.
La Cupola, come Internet,
ha portato avanti informazioni
per la prossima generazione.
E dopo 25 anni di Internet,
io oggi, come regista,
ho nelle mie mani cineprese digitali,
suono, editing, Final Cut.
È il metodo di portare
le mie storie a tutto il mondo.
C'è un'altra cosa molto importante.
Grandi idee come la Cupola
hanno stimolato una grande collaborazione.
La città di Firenze ha riunito
i suoi migliori cittadini:
uomini d'affari, artigiani,
gente che lavorava con le mani
e ha fatto due domande:
"If not now, when?"
"E se non noi, chi?"
(Applausi)
Vi domando:
si può immaginare la città di Firenze
senza la cupola al centro del suo cuore?
La palla e la croce sono diventate
fari universali per tutto il mondo.
Per il pensiero, per la democrazia.
E ora siamo all'inizio di una nuova epoca.
La gente guarda Internet anziché leggerlo.
I nostri bambini imparano
a vedere e poi a fare,
come gli artigiani umanisti dell'epoca.
Io credo che la tecnologia
sia la cosa per cui noi viviamo.
È importante come l'amore,
come la cittadinanza,
e come la vita sociale.
Quest'uomo m'ha dato grande ispirazione.
Quando ha iniziato il progetto
della Cupola aveva 42 anni.
Come me, ora.
E non aveva ancora iniziato
il suo capolavoro:
una cosa che nessuno voleva fare.
Guardate...
Il mio film non potrà mai, mai mai mai
superare l'immensità della Cupola.
Ma forse posso, davanti al mondo,
onorare questo figlio fiorentino:
un genio che ha portato grande fortuna
a questa bellissima città.
Viva Firenze.
Evviva Filippo Brunelleschi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)